et aujourd'hui mardi 29 mars la
mobilisation du syndicat sud du centre
hospitalier de versailles continue ils
s'étaient donné rendez vous à midi dont
le haut le mignot pour une marche en
direction de l'agencé régionale de santé
de versailles les revendications sont
toujours les mêmes ils dénoncent les
suppressions de plus d'une centaine de
postes programmées par la direction de
l'établissement sur les deux ans à venir
différents types de postes sont menacés
secrétaire et soignants infirmières et
agents de service hospitalier alors que
l'activité de l'hôpital ne faiblit pas
ces suppressions destinée à compenser le
coût croissant des travaux de
modernisation de centre hospitalier
beaucoup plus cher que prévu
selon le syndicat sud les bétails au
micro de sephora mamani
aujourd'hui on peut pas tolérer que le
personnel morfle alors que l'hôpital
tourne à plein les personnels sont
épuisées il ya des burnout enfin des
services complets en burn out et en fait
ce qui nous met dans financièrement
c'est les travaux uniquement les travaux
plus le financement t2a mais voilà